ああああああ
bejean
はじめまして小林弘明と申します
皆さんは吃音という言葉を聞いたことがありますか
吃音とは言葉が灯ることを言います
例えば cocco こんにちはと音が繰り返したり
コーン日はと音が伸びたり
こんにちはと音が詰まって出て来なかったりします
僕はこの吃音と2つの関わりがあります
一つは当事者としての関わりです
僕にはこの質問があります僕に初めて吃音が出てきたのは3歳くらいの時だったそう
ですしかし不思議と
小学校までは吃音なことで悩んだ記憶がありません
僕が質問に悩むようになったのは中学生になってからです
思春期になるとみんなと同じということが大事になりますしかし吃音があるとぼーぼぼ
僕のように
オカシな話し方になってしまい他の人と同じように話せません
そのため僕は人様に劣っているダメな人間だと思うようになりました
そしてと思っては難しい御油するのではないかとビクビクし
話すのをやめてしまったりすることもたくさんありました
それから心身所はが医学という障害のあるある人についての研究をする大学院に入学し
きつ本を研究することになりましたしかし最初が吃音だけは研究したくないと思ってい
ました
それぐらい僕の中で基調に対するコンプレックスが大きかったもの
ですね
しかし大学院での研究テーマを選ぼうとするときにどうしても室温以外のテーマで
学校行ってきませんでしたしかし吃音であれば自分自身がこれまで経験したことの中
から研究したい事を知りたいことがたくさんありました
そこで最初がやむをえないという感じで
吃音の研究を始めましたん
大学院を修了後金沢大学で勤務しています
以前と比べる道僕の一音がだいぶ軽くなりました
僕の吃音が歩くなったのには
理由が2つほどあると考えています
一つは
大学教員として
講義や学会発表することで
人前で話すことに慣れたことだと思います
23歳のときに初めて学会発表をしたのですがその時はひどくと思ってしまい
現行の半分も読み上げることができませんでした
しかし今では吃音が出る時はありますがだいたい8
考えた事は全部発表できるようになっています
軽くなったもう一つの理由は家族の存在です
両親が僕の一音を審判一つも過度に気遣うことなく
温かく見守ってくれましたまた私は32歳で結婚したのですが妻は私の質問のことを
何事もないように普通に受け入れてくれました
家族が明け入れてくれたっパケで僕自身も自分の吃音を受け入れられたように感じてい
ます
でも47歳になった今でも僕の吃音は完全には治ってみません
例えば列車の切符をみどりの窓口で買うときは今でも苦手ですキュッポーがを時は
行き先や時刻や列車ウェイなどを言わなくてはいけませんがそういった
の中に話しにくい言葉がある度
うまく言えるかと敬意さんの前で非常に緊張します
檀店がも苦手な場面のひとつです
特に自分の所属先である金沢大学という言葉を言う時に詰まって言葉が出てこないこと
がありますそうする
をもしもしもしもしと言われたり
どうかしましたかという風に言われてしまうことがあります
そうすると
不安と緊張が高まりになお余計に話しにくくなってしまいます
僕の話はこれは稀にして吃音のことについてお話ししたいと思います
質問のある人は幼児期には5%
小学校行こうが1%程度いると言われています
なお幼児期の蜜本の78割は自然治癒すると言われています
歴史の中でも吃音が古くから知られていました
例えば古代ギリシャ時代に井川の父と呼ばれた
ヒポクラテス8番幕の祖と称せられるアリストテレスは吃音について言及しています
日本では東京師範学校などの校長を歴任し
貴族院議員まで務めた伊沢修二心が明治期の好機に落石車
という質問矯正施設を開設しています
落石者は内務省の助成金を得たこともあり昭和の初期には2万人記事
今日の吃音のある人の共生に当たったと言われています
落石者の質問調整は伊沢氏がアメリカに留学している時に
でんがを発明したベルシーから学んだしば方という
発生髪は方
の訓練と精神氷河訓練を組み合わせたものだったようです
ただ学籍者の実本矯正を受けた人の中には調整を受けている間は室温が少なくなったの
だけれども
調整を終え子も自分の地元に帰ったら再びで吃音が出てきたという人もいたようです
これまで質問に関する数多くの研究がされていますが残念だから不都合の原因はまだ
解明されてきません
現在入力されている普通無限陰嚢としてた要因理論があります
これは室温が単独の要因でしょうジウンではなくいくつかの要因が見合わされて生じる
という説です
たとえばアメリカの吃音研究者のバリエギター氏は
これまで研究されてきた不都合の原因論を
対応演技論の観点から2段階モデルとして整理しています
ディランパイン触れるでは室温の失言には言語発達のアンバランスな状態と心理学的な
学習の2つの状態が関わっていると考えます
言語発達のアンバランスアウトは言葉を理解する力が高く
話したいことがたくさん思い浮かぶのだけれども
言葉で表現する力が十分に育っていないため頭の中で話したいことがいっぱいあるのだ
けれどもそれがスムーズに言葉となって出てこない状態を今
ます心理学的な学習とは取ることを叱責されたりからかわれたりする経験を重ねること
で話す前に事前受けたからかいや叱責
から出た恥ずかしさや不安緊張が蘇ることを言います
吃音の原因はまだ解明されていませんが親の育て方が悪かったり本人の性格の問題で
あったり
知的運動発達の問題であるという説はこれまで検証された上で否定されていますしかし
僕な運営している2オンポータルサイトというホームページには
ああああああ
お子さんの吃音が親御さんのせいですねと言われたりあるいは
病院に行ってき2胸おいてこい室温ぐらい直さないとダメだと言われた樽の相談を
受けることがあります
残念ながら吃音に対する社会全般の理解はまだまだ十分ではなくこのような偏見や誤解
がたくさんあるようですこのような考えは間違っているだけではなく質問のある人や
その保護者の方をしつつ系深く悲しませます
質問の金ないな症状は一人一人様々です
室ゴンのある人の中にはたくさんのボルけど
とも6とへの不安や緊張がなく吃音への混乱あまりないという人がありますまた
ほとんどと守らないけれども寄贈に対する不安や緊張が高く大きな劣等感
8今何を感じているという人もいます
質問ので安いことが場面も人それぞれ様々です
吃音のある人の中には自分の名前やハイをこんにちは
などの簡単な言葉が出てこないという人があります
また電話は相手の顔が見えないから苦手だという人もいれば相手の顔が見えないから気
が楽だという人もいます
私は大学にある小さな相談室で質問のある人も相談をしています
吃音は標準的な治療法はまだ確立されていません
しかしこれまでの
地道がで印象の積み重ねによりいくつか
有効な方法が見出されていますそれらはまとめると以下の3つになります
一つ目は周囲の人に質問のある人の周囲にいる人に詰問を理解していただくことです
質問のある人がしばしば受ける5回に慌てているのだろう
焦っているのだろうというのがあります
そのため周囲の人が吹かれと思って落ち着いてとか
ディランハウスとしてとかえっと声をかけて実家レベルのですが
紅の声掛けで帰ってー詰問のある人が不安が緊張が高まってしまう場合があります
また必要のある人の多くはどんなに話し方
お気を付けても気だが2死をリラックスしようと思っても言葉が出てこないときがあり
ます
そこで周囲の方にはこのことをぜひご理解いただき
言葉が出てこない時には言葉が出るまで待っていただいたり
釜内では夏スラスラ話すというような話し方の形に価値を置き次ないでいただきたいの
です
さらに質問のある人がしばしは苦しく吃音のがる人をしばしば苦しめる問題に吃音に
対するかな海があります
吃音のある人がどころかもしれないという不安と戦いながら一生懸命がなそうとしてい
ます
そのことををくみ取りいただき
吃音に対するから会例えば払うとか真似をするとか
1言うとかそういったことはやめていただければ嬉しいです
二つ目は質問のある人自身が吃音を理解することです
質問のある人の中には
吃音うことを悪いことをいけないことと感じている人が多くいます
また2音があると友達や恋人ができないと思ったり
就職ができないと思ったりしている人も多くいます
しかし室温は生まれつきのものであり悪いこといけないことで理由
してありませんまた
友達や恋人がたくさんいる吃音の人もいますし
あるいは社会で活躍している既存の人も多くいます
吃音のある方には是非このことも知っていただきたいと思います
また吃音の標準的な治療法は確立していませんがこれまでの臨床実践の中で初ば速度の
調節や口や窓をやら爆動かすといった
詰問になりにくい話し方の習得を目指す
いう調整形成法という方法や自身の2
ように直面をし普通に対する不安や恐怖を軽減したり苦しい詰まる話し方から抜け出し
方を考えたりするし都合の考え方というような治療法その他にもいろいろありますが
そういうふうなものが確立しています
開発されていますまたそういった専門的な
は治療が小学校の中にあることばの教室という教室や病院の言語リハビリの
a 棟外来などで受けることができます
吃音のある人にはこのこともぜひ知っていただきたいと思います
さらに質問のある人は100人に1人と意外と多くいること
また質問のある人もセルフヘルプグループが全国各地にありそれぞれが積極的な活動を
着ているということも知っていただきたいと思います
3つ目は質問のある人をクックルシべる不安金城越冬館へのアプローチです
アメリカの有名な吃音研究者の番外パー4は質問の困難を克服するには
俺 r を高める必要があると述べています
もらえるには資金とか意気込みとかという意味があります
ああああああ
思ってる恥ずかしい思いをするかもしれないという不安や金城はとてもとても辛く
しんどいものです
しかし私は
このえっと不安を克服していくためには
ボラールを持ち話すことから地下ないで挑戦していくことが大事だと考えています私は
そのことを大学の教育相談に来られる方や質問のセルフヘルプグループで出会った赤間
からあナビました
例えば教育認証相談で出会ったある青年が私が主宰する
吃音のある中高生も集いに車で片道5時間をかけんきてくれました
そして大学への振動で選ぶにあたり
質問で困っているちっちゃな子供を助けたいという気持ちから教育学部に進学
福祉教育実習やサークルや
ブランティアに吃音が出ることを悩みながらも一生懸命取り組みました
そして就職活動教員採用試験を受けたのですが
では面接で自身に吃音があることでその吃音のある経験を
障害や困難で困っている子供たちの教育の役に立てたいという方
go 堂々と述べたのです
このような態度がまたいっ
5号の不安や恐怖に怯え話すことから質問から逃げていた自分とはまったく異なります
そしてこのようなベッドまだ
若いのにこのような
ことができるえっ彼女にはたちは8た金森さと尊敬を覚えました
今回イン
ペットてデックスの話を頂いたときにまず感じたのは何か面白そうというワクワクした
気持ちでした
しかし同時にうまく話せるだろうかと思ってる恥ずかしい思いに住むではないかという
不安を同じぐらい大きく感じました
それでも私が今回
ここで発表しようと思ったのは以下の2つの理由によります
一つは
わくわくすることにいつまでも挑戦し続ける
そういう若い自分でありたいいつまでもこう
調整続ける自分でありたいと思ったことが一つですで2つ目は今回のスピーチを通し
質問に興味関心を持っていただき
室温に対する社会的な理解が進むことそのことによって室温による誤解や偏見で悩んで
いる吃音の人の悩みが少しでも少なくなればと思ったからです
最後にここにいるみなさんに考えてほしいことがありますそれは吃音のある人がどころ
かもしれないと言う
不安と戦いながらそれでも一生懸命話そうとしていることです
そのことをぜひ理解していただき
言葉が出てこない時には言葉が出てくるまで少し待っていただく
このことで既存のある人はずいぶん楽になると思います
本日はどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]